The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
ALAN OPPENHEIM: In
the last lecture,
we began the discussion
of the computation
of the discrete
Fourier transform.
And in particular, we developed
a flow graph for one algorithm.
The algorithm that we
talked about last time,
which is referred to as
the decimation in time
form of the fast Fourier
transform algorithm,
was derived by decomposing
the original sequence
into subsequences.
First, two subsequences
consisting of the even numbered
points and the odd
numbered points,
implementing an N-over-2-point
DFT on the even numbered points
and an N-over-2-point DFT
on the odd numbered points,
and then combining those results
in an appropriate way to obtain
the discrete Fourier transform
of the overall sequence.
And we saw, first
of all, that there
was a computational efficiency
that resulted from doing this.
And furthermore, we
recognized that we
could continue
this decomposition
and thereby achieve an
even greater efficiency.
In particular, with N
expressed as a power of 2,
we could continue decomposing
the N-over-2-point DFTs
into N-over-4-point DFTs,
the N-over-4-point DFTs
into N-over-8-point
DFTs, et cetera.
The flow graph
that resulted when
we did this was the flow
graph indicated here,
which is the one that
we derived last time.
It consists essentially of a
set of butterfly computations--
what we refer to
as butterflies--
a multiplication on
the bottom branch
of the butterfly at the
input to the butterfly,
and then an addition
and subtraction.
And that basically is
the type of computation
that follows throughout
the flow graph.
Now, this is a flow
graph representing
the computation of the
discrete Fourier transform.
And what is important
about the flow graph
are the nodes and the
connections between the nodes
and the transmittances
on the branches
that connect the nodes together.
However, the flow graph in
the form that is depicted here
suggests a strategy
for organizing
the computation of the DFT.
In particular, what we recognize
is that the flow graph in this
form tends, in a natural
way, to suggest organizing
the computation corresponding
to a computation of an input
array-- a computation
on an input array--
computing a second array at
this stage, from these points,
computing this array,
and from these points,
finally computing the
DFT output points.
If we do that and we in
fact think of these points
as corresponding to
sequential memory registers,
then we know, first of
all, that the input points
would be stored sequentially,
not in their normal order,
but in fact, in
some altered order.
And as you'll see
in a few minutes,
what this order corresponds
to and will be referred
to as is bit reversed order.
However, an additional
point that I'd
like to make first
about this flow graph,
and that is that
it corresponds--
when thought of as a
procedure for organizing
the computation--
corresponds to an
in-place computation
of the discrete
Fourier transform.
Now, what I mean by
that is the following.
Let's suppose that we
think of this set of points
as corresponding to
sequential registers in memory
and we'd like to compute
from this set of points
this second array that is
the set of points here.
What we notice is that
because of the butterfly
structure of this
computation, it
is these two points that are
used to compute these two
points in the next array.
These points are used
to compute these two
points in the next
array, et cetera,
so that in fact, we can organize
the computation by implementing
the computation required
on these two input points,
storing the results in a
corresponding set of memory
locations, which in fact
could be the original memory
locations from which we
took these data points.
The reason for that
is that once we've
used these two data points,
we don't need them any longer.
And so the result
of this butterfly
we could in fact store back in
the original memory locations.
And a few minutes of reflection
on this flow graph in general
would indicate that this is
true throughout the computation.
It's clearly true in
going from the first stage
to the second stage.
In proceeding from this
stage to the next stage,
we see again, for example in
computing these two points,
the only input points
that we use are these two.
So again we could
think of storing
the result of this computation
for this butterfly,
for example, back in the
original memory locations.
So if we think of nodes on
the same horizontal line
as corresponding to
identical memory registers,
then we see that with
the computation organized
in the way that this
flow graph suggests,
that in fact the computation
can be done in place.
And we'll see that with
some other alternative forms
of the FFT algorithm, some
alternative forms of this flow
graph, there perhaps
are other advantages,
but for some of the
other flow graphs,
the computation can no
longer be done in-place.
So first of all, this
flow graph represents
an in-place algorithm.
Second of all, the input points
are in some altered order,
although the DFT
output points come out
in what is normal order.
That is, sequential order if
we think of these as sequential
registers.
Well, let's examine in a little
more detail what the order is
that is being generated here.
If we simply look at
the memory registers
and the corresponding data index
from the previous flow graph,
in storage registers 0
we're storing x of 0,
in storage register 1
we're storing x of 4,
storage register 2, x
of 2, and et cetera.
These are the storage
register locations.
These are the data indices.
If we write the storage
register locations in binary
and we write the data index
in binary, what we see,
interestingly enough,
is that the data index
is the bit reversed counterpart
of the storage register index.
So here, for example, we
have 001, storage register 1.
Here we have 100,
which is data index 4.
And this continues
on throughout.
110 is storage register
6, bit reversed is 011,
which is data index 3.
Now, it's not accidental that
this developed in such a way
that the data is in fact
stored in a bit reversed order.
The reason for that basically
is because of the way
in which we originally
sorted the sequence
into the even numbered
points and the odd numbered
points, then the even numbered
of the even numbered points,
and the odd numbered of the
even numbered points, et cetera.
In particular, suppose that we
considered a tree to carry out
the sorting that we
implemented in breaking
the original sequence
up into subsequences.
Well, we started with
the original sequence
and we divided that into two
subsequences, one corresponding
to the even numbered points,
the second corresponding
to the odd numbered points.
If you look at the binary
representation of the data
index, you can identify
the even numbered points
by the points for which the
least significant binary bit is
a 0 and the odd numbered
points for which the least
significant binary bit is a 1.
So we divided the original
sequence into two subsequences.
The top half all had 0 as
the least significant bit.
The bottom half all had 1 as
Well, then for the
even numbered points
we wanted to divide those into
the even numbered of the even
numbered and the odd numbered
of the even numbered.
How would we do that?
Well, we would do
that by examining
the next least significant bit.
If that's a 0, then we
would identify the data
as being an even numbered
of the even numbered points.
If it's a 1, it's
an odd numbered
of the even numbered points.
So this data was sorted
as we've indicated here.
And then, of course,
we continue on looking
at the bits from the
right to the left.
So sorting, then we could
sort in the order that
resulted by constructing a
tree, as I've indicated here,
and examining the bits
from the right to the left.
Suppose that we wanted
instead to sort the data,
not as I've indicated
here, but in normal order.
In other words, we
have a bucket of data.
We want to sort the data so
that the data index comes out
in normal order.
How would we do that with a
similar type of tree structure?
Well, to decide whether
the data index is
in the top half
or the bottom half
we would look at the
most significant bit.
If the most
significant bit is a 0,
then the data is in the top
half of the entire set of data.
And if the most
significant bit is a 1,
the data is in the bottom half.
Next, we would proceed to the
second most significant bit.
If the second most
significant bit is a 0,
then we fall either into
the top half of the top half
or the top half of
the bottom half.
And we continue on like that
going through a tree exactly
identical to this,
but examining the bits
for sorting in normal order from
the most significant bit down
to the least significant bit.
So it is basically that in
sorting the data as we sorted
it to develop the flow
graph that we developed,
we examined the bits in
exactly the reverse order
that we would examine
the bits if we wanted
to sort the data normally.
And consequently what results
is data that's sorted in bit
reversed order.
Incidentally, speaking of
things being bit reversed,
the view graph as I first
got it back from drafting I
thought you might
enjoy looking at.
And if you find
your mind wandering
during the rest of
the lecture, you
might try to figure out exactly
what happened with this view
graph.
The first inclination is that
I simply have it turned around,
so we can try that.
Well, that doesn't quite do it.
So maybe we should turn it over.
And that doesn't quite do it.
And in fact, I haven't yet
been able to figure out
a way of sorting this particular
view graph in any normal order
and I'd be curious as to
whether you can figure out
a way to straighten it out.
Well, in any case,
what we have then is
a sorting of the original data--
returning now to the flow
graph that we saw previously--
a sorting of the
original data in bit
reversed order and the output
resulting in normal order.
Well, of course this
isn't the only way
to organize the computation of
the discrete Fourier transform.
And in fact, an important
aspect of the flow graph
is as I stressed previously
that what counts about the flow
graph are the nodes and the
way they're connected and not
the way the flow graph
is laid out in a sheet.
When it's laid
out in a sheet, we
were able to apply some
additional interpretation
having to do with a way of
organizing the computation
from stage to stage.
But it's important to recognize
that if you take this flow
graph, roll it up in a ball,
as long as the right points are
connected to the
right points, then
it still represents
a computation
of the discrete
Fourier transform.
So in particular, we are free
to rearrange this flow graph
in any way that we
would like to as long
as we don't change the
connections between the notes.
Well, one possible thought is
to rearrange the flow graph
so that we avoid this problem
of bit reversal on the input.
We can think of
rearranging these lines
so that the input is changed
to an input in normal order.
And one way of
doing that, in fact,
is to simply take all
of the horizontal lines
and rearrange them so that
the data is sorted correctly.
So we would leave
this line where
it is, we would take this
line and move it up to here,
this line would then stay where
it is, this line would move up,
and they would continue
to be rearranged.
The input would be
then in normal order,
the output, of course,
would be disturbed,
and we could anticipate
exactly how it's
going to be disturbed, in fact.
The output then will come
out in bit reversed order.
That flow graph is then
as I've indicated here.
And this then corresponds
to a rearrangement
of the previous
flow graph, where
we have rearranged the
computation so that the input
is now in normal order.
The way in which we rearranged
it, the output then comes out
in bit reversed order.
Incidentally, on most of
the following view graphs,
I have indicated a reference to
the figure in the text, which
this view graph corresponds
to, because in fact, many
of these flow graphs will
be going through quite
a number of flow graphs.
Many of them look
very similar, so I
thought perhaps a reference
to the figure in the text
will help you keep
them organized.
So now we have a modification
of the decimation
in time form of
the FFT algorithm,
which is such that
if we now think
of this as the procedure for
organizing the computation,
the input is now
in normal order,
the output is in
bit reversed order.
Have we destroyed the fact
that the original computation
was an in-place computation?
Well, in fact, we
haven't, because if we
look at this now the way
that it's organized, again,
thinking of this as
sequential memory registers,
then, again, if we, for
example, select this butterfly,
the computation of
these two points
requires only these
two input points.
So once we have used
these two points,
we can store them back in the
original memory locations.
What makes the flow
graph correspond
to an in-place
computation is the fact
that the output nodes
of the butterfly
are horizontally adjacent to the
input nodes of the butterfly.
If that property of the
flow graph is destroyed,
then the flow graph will
no longer correspond
to an in-place
computation if we think
of all nodes on the
same horizontal line
as corresponding to
identical memory registers,
or equivalently, that
vertical nodes correspond
to sequential memory registers.
Well, there are a
variety of other ways
in which we can rearrange
this flow graph.
We can, of course,
modify the flow graph
so that we have not only
normal order at the input,
but so that we also have
normal order at the output.
And we can do that
simply by demanding it.
In other words, by
rearranging these nodes,
keeping these nodes in normal
order, rearranging these
nodes so that they also
correspond to normal order.
And the flow graph that
results in that case
is the one that
I've indicated here.
So this is now the
decimation in time form
of the algorithm
with the input sorted
in normal order and the output
also sorted in normal order.
The computation still is
represented by butterflies,
but the butterflies
are distorted.
In other words, each
of the butterflies
no longer corresponds
to the computation
of horizontally adjacent
nodes in the flow graph.
So in fact, this
computation is no longer
an in-place computation.
Well, is it an in-place
computation from this array
to this one?
As it happens, it is in the
computation of the first array,
the reason being that in each
of the butterflies, again,
the output nodes
are horizontally
adjacent to the input nodes.
But that property is
lost after this array.
And proceeding from this
array to this array,
we see that to compute
these two points--
let's take this
one and this one--
we need this point
and this point.
So we couldn't store then
this answer back in here
because we're going
to need this point
to compute some other
output points, et cetera.
So this flow graph in this
form has the disadvantage
that the in-place computational
aspects of the flow graph
are lost although the
input is in normal order
and the output is
in normal order.
It has another
disadvantage incidentally,
and that is that the indexing is
somewhat difficult in contrast
to the two flow graphs
that we've talked about
so far where the indexing
strategy is relatively
straightforward
from stage to stage.
Now, there's another
rearrangement
of this flow graph which
has some advantages and also
some disadvantages.
First, let me return to
the original flow graph
that we began with, which
consisted of the input sorted
in bit reversed order and the
output sorted in normal order.
The indexing in
this flow graph is
relatively straightforward
in that you should notice
that as you proceed
from stage to stage,
the width of the butterflies
continues to double.
So here the width
of the butterfly
is 1, here the width
of the butterfly is 2--
or the height of the butterfly--
here the height of
the butterfly is 4.
If we were computing a
larger order transform,
then that procedure
would continue.
But as you can imagine, if
we were implementing this
on a computer or with
special purpose hardware,
because of the fact that
the data separation as we
compute each butterfly
increases or changes as we
go from stage to
stage, what is required
is random access memory.
We require random access
memory because in each array
we are not accessing data
from sequential registers.
We are going from this
array to this one.
After that, in
computing a butterfly,
we no longer are accessing
sequential registers.
There is, however, a
modification of this algorithm
which is useful in the sense
that it permits the computation
without random access
memory and in particular
is organized so that it can
utilize sequential memory,
although it does not correspond
to an in-place computation.
And that form of the algorithm,
I have indicated here,
is a form of the
algorithm that originally
was proposed by singleton.
This then is a form of the
decimation in time algorithm.
It's a rearrangement
of the flowchart
so that sequential memory can be
used rather than random access
memory.
Let me point out first
of all that the input is
in bit reversed order, the
output is in normal order,
and now let me explain
in a little more detail
why this flow graph allows
the use of sequential memory
rather than random
access memory.
First of all, let me indicate
that the organization
of this flow graph is
identical from stage to stage.
In other words, if you think
of how this piece of the flow
graph looks in computing
the first stage,
it is exactly the same
with regard to data
access as computing
this stage is
in relation to
the one before it,
and this continues on through.
So as opposed to the other
forms of the algorithm,
the indexing is
identical from stage
to stage in this form
of the algorithm.
Now, to utilize sequential
memory-- sequential memory
might be disk memory or drum
memory or shift register
memory, for example.
Generally, bulk memory is
sequential memory rather than
random access.
Let's think of the original
data first shuffled
in bit reversed
order and then stored
in two separate memories.
Let's call them M
sub A and M sub B.
The first half of
the data is stored
in memory A. The second half of
the data is stored in memory B.
And then let's permit two
additional sequential memory
registers, memories
M sub C and M sub D
for storing the output
of the computation.
Then the computation would
proceed essentially as follows.
We would access the first two
data points from memory A,
use those to compute the
first point in this array,
store that in memory C, and use
that to compute the first point
in the second half of
this array and store
that in memory D. Next, we
would access the next two input
points from memory
A, add those--
we would do the required
computation-- store
the result in the next
location in memory A,
also store the second
half of the butterfly
output in the second
register in memory D.
So as we proceed along, we
access the first two points
from memory A then the next
two points from memory A,
storing in memory
C and memory D.
When we have gone through
the first half of the data,
we now access the data from
the second input memory,
memory B, the first two points,
do the required computation,
and store in the next
sequential registers in memory C
and memory D, et cetera.
So the strategy
in this case, then
is that the input is stored half
in memory A, half in memory B.
The data is first
accessed from memory A
and we alternately put
results in memories C and D.
When we finish with memory A,
we then proceed to memory B,
access data sequentially,
and continue
to store the results
alternating in memory C and D.
Now that gives us the
result at this stage.
To compute the next stage,
we now start with the memory
C and D as the inputs and store
the results of the computation
back into memories A
and B. So in a sense,
you can think of
the computation then
as involving four memory, four
separate sequential memories,
A, B, C, and D. We
start with A and B,
flush the data into memory C and
D, then flush the results back.
And in fact, you can
think of the computation
much the same way
as a slinky toy
where you bounce the data back
and forth between these two
sets of sequential memories.
That then is a form of
the computation which
is not an in-place computation.
And furthermore, the
input is bit reversed,
although the output
is in normal order,
and it has the
advantage, though,
that the indexing is
identical from stage to stage
and consequently can utilize
sequential memory rather
than requiring
random access memory.
Well, that then completes the
discussion of the decimation
in time form of the algorithm.
There are, of course, a number
of other variations on this
and some of them are
discussed in the text.
What I'd like to proceed to now
is a slightly different form
of FFT algorithms
which are really
derived on a somewhat different
basis than the decimation
in time form of the algorithms.
But we'll see as
we finally continue
the discussion that there
is a very close relationship
between the decimation
in time algorithms
as we've just talked about and
the class of algorithms which
I would now like
to introduce, which
are the decimation in frequency
forms of the FFT algorithm.
Well, in particular,
the notion in deriving
the decimation and frequency
forms of the FFT algorithm
is, essentially, rather
than breaking the input up
into the even numbered and
the odd numbered points,
organize the computation so that
we compute separately the even
numbered and odd
numbered output points.
In particular, let's look
again at the general form
for the discrete
Fourier transform x of k
given by this sum and let's
consider decomposing this
into a sum over the first
half of the input points
and a sum over the second
half of the input points.
Well, the sum over the
second half of the input
points we can rearrange somewhat
differently by essentially
implementing a
substitution of variables
so that the index on the sum
is changed to an index from 0
to N over 2 minus 1.
And if we do that, the
sum that results then,
the expression that
results, is W sub N
to the N over 2 k times the sum
of x of n plus capital N over 2
times W sub N to the nk.
And you can easily check
that this is correct.
For example, for little n
equal to capital N over 2
here, we have x of
capital N over 2 W sub N
to the capital N over 2 k.
Here, for little n equals 0,
we get W sub N to the capital
N over 2 k times x
of capital N over 2,
and this term becomes 1.
Just simply a
substitution of variables.
Well, we recognize this term,
W sub n to the N over 2 k,
is equal to minus 1.
And consequently,
then we can rewrite
this as I've
indicated here, x of k
is equal to a sum from n equals
0 to N over 2 minus 1 of x of n
plus minus 1 to the k--
k being the index on the DFT--
times x of n plus capital
N over 2 W sub N to the nk.
Well, it's tempting to look at
this and say kind of in analogy
with the decimation in time--
the steps we took in the
decimation time algorithm,
that this is an
N-over-2-point DFT.
It is a sum from 0
to N over 2 minus 1,
it's a modified input sequence,
but it's not, in fact,
an N-over-2-point DFT.
And the reason that it isn't is
that this is W sub N to the nk
whereas if it was an
N-over-2-point DFT,
this would be W sub
capital N over 2 to the nk.
However, let's look at these DFT
points for two separate cases,
one being that for which
the index, the output index,
is even and the second for
which the output index is odd.
The output index
is even, then we
can think of that as indexing
through the DFT points
with an argument x of 2r,
where r ranges from 0 to N
over 2 minus 1.
And we then have this sum since
k is even, minus 1 to the k
is positive and we have
then this sum that I've
indicated here,
whereas for k odd,
we choose an index 2r plus 1,
where again r ranges from 0
to N over 2 minus 1.
And because k is odd,
what results in the sum
is a subtraction rather
than an addition.
And then we have
substituting in also.
We have W sub capital N to the
little n times W sub capital
N to the 2rn.
Now, finally, we can take
advantage of the fact
that W sub N to the 2rn
can be written in terms
of W sub capital N over 2.
In particular, W sub
capital N to the 2rn
is equal to W sub capital
N over 2 to the rn.
And that follows as it did
and we utilize that fact also
in deriving the decimation in
time form of the algorithm.
It follows simply
by substituting
in to the expression
for W sub capital N.
Finally utilizing
this, we recognize
that for the
computation of the DFT
for that the output index
even, the computation
can be reduced to a sum of a
sequence g of n, where g of n
is the sum of the first half and
the last half of the input data
points.
That multiplied by W sub
capital N over 2 to the rn.
Well, this is now an
N-over-2-point discrete Fourier
transform.
It involves N-over-2-points and
the powers of W involved are
the appropriate
powers of W for--
or rather the W is involved
is the appropriate W
for an N-over-2-point DFT.
That's indicated by
this subscript N over 2.
So this is to compute
the even numbered points.
To compute the odd
numbered points,
we have a similar expression.
We have the sum of h of n
times W sub capital N to the n,
and that times W sub N over
2 to the rn, where h of n
is the difference between the
first half of the data points
and the last half
of the data points.
So basically, following
this strategy,
what this says is that we can
compute the discrete Fourier
transform by forming
a subsequence,
which is the sum of the first
and last half of the points,
and computing the
N-over-2-point DFT of that,
and then forming a sequence,
which is the difference
of the first and the last
half of the input points,
multiplying that by W sub
capital N to the little n,
and computing the
N-over-2-point DFT of that.
And if you count up the
number of operations involved,
multiplications
and additions, you
will find that there is
exactly the same computational
efficiency implied
in this decomposition
as there was as we went
through the decimation
in time form of the algorithm.
So this then is the basis for
the decimation in time form
of the computation and it
basically states that we would
compute the discrete Fourier
transform by first forming
a subsequence, which
we denoted as g,
which we obtain by adding the
first half of the input points
to the last half of
the input points,
and implementing an
N-over-2-point DFT of that
to obtain the even
numbered output points.
And then we would subtract the
first half of the input points
from the last half
of the input points,
multiply that subsequence,
h, by successive powers of W,
compute an N-over-2-point
DFT of that,
and the result would then be
the odd numbered output points.
Well, just as we did
with the decimation
in time form of the algorithm,
we can continue this procedure.
In other words, we can decompose
the N-over-2-point DFTs
into N-over-4-point DFTs
by adding the first half
of the input points here to
the last half, et cetera.
As we proceed
through, we would then
develop a flow graph in
which we would compute first
the even numbered of the
even numbered output points
and then the odd numbered of
the even numbered output points,
et cetera.
So you can imagine that as
we proceed through this,
we'll get a flow graph.
Similar in many respects
to the flow graph
that we developed
for the decimation
in time form of the algorithm,
and furthermore, the flow graph
as it naturally
develops this way will
result in data, the DFT output,
sorted in a bit reversed order.
So continuing on then, here
is the decomposition with
the N-over-2-point DFTs broken
into N-over-4-point DFTs,
and we are now computing the
even numbered of the even
numbered output points first.
The N-over-4-point DFTs, if we
consider the specific case of N
equals 8, the N-over-4-point
DFTs are just simply 2-point
DFTs, which involve, as they did
in the decimation in time form
of the algorithm, just simply
a computation involving
an addition and a subtraction.
In other words, just
a simple butterfly.
So the resulting
flow graph based
on pursuing this strategy
through the entire computation
is as I've indicated
here, which is
one form of the
decimation in frequency
form of the algorithm.
Notice that the input
is in normal order,
the output is in bit reversed
order, the flow graph
as it developed here,
again, if we think
of it as a
computational strategy,
a strategy for organizing
the computation,
again, corresponds to
an in-place computation.
It's an in-place computation
because output nodes
for a butterfly are horizontally
adjacent to the input
nodes of the butterfly.
In many respects,
in fact, it looks
somewhat like the decimation
in time form of the algorithm
when we sorted things such that
the input was in normal order
and the output was in
bit reversed order.
In fact, there is a
difference between this class
of algorithms and the decimation
in time form of the algorithm.
One difference that I would
just draw your attention to
quickly is the fact that the
butterflies in the decimation
in frequency form
of the algorithm,
as we've just been
talking about it,
involve additions
and subtractions,
and the multiplication
by powers of W
is implemented on the
output of the butterfly.
Whereas for the decimation in
time form of the algorithm,
the multiplication by a power of
W was implemented at the input
to the butterfly followed by
an addition and subtraction.
So in fact, the decimation
and frequency form
of the algorithm as
we've just developed it
is somewhat different
than the decimation
in time form of the algorithm.
As we'll see as we continue
in the next lecture,
there are modifications of
this form of the algorithm
just as there were
for the decimation
in time form of the algorithm.
And we'll also see
that in fact there
is a very close relationship
between these two
forms of the algorithm, the
relationship being suggested
by properties of flow graphs
that we've discussed in some
of the previous lectures.
So at this point, then we
have concluded our discussion
of the decimation in time
forms of the algorithm,
we've introduced the
decimation in frequency form
of the algorithm.
In the next lecture,
what I would like to do
is continue on a discussion
of the decimation in frequency
forms, in particular discussing
alternative forms which
are similar to the
alternative forms
that we discussed for
decimation in time.
Thank you.